and big results after an eight news now
investigation into one homeowner's
struggle switching to solar the
homeowners in this case actually got a
go to debate news now because of our
previous investigation and now another
solar power dispute has a happy ending a
New Zealand investigator Kyle Payne
joining us with the report of solar
success Kyle Friday we reported on a
homeowner in North Las Vegas whose
electric bills were nowhere near as low
as he was promised just before our story
went on the air we heard from Titan
solar who guaranteed us they'd find a
resolution
I want them to make me happy with the
original deal or they put 11 more panels
up you know
on at their expense at their expense you
know what we know now is the Titan solar
of Nevada is making homeowner John
tacona as happy as they can installing
11 new solar panels at no cost saving
him about 15 grand after he shelled out
26 000 on the original set of panels
which weren't working costing him
hundreds of dollars on electric bills
more than he expected and much much more
than he can afford this went against
everything I was trying to do tacona of
North Las Vegas tried everything he
struck out with renewable energy of
Nevada which talked him into switching
to solar in the first place and he got
nowhere with Titan solar who installed
the wrong system he even complained to
some state agencies and the Attorney
General opened an investigation into his
claims and then he called the 8 news now
investigators and when we got in touch
with Titan solar they got right on it
guaranteeing the issue would be resolved
two days later a representative from
Titan solar was at the tacona's home and
they sent all the paperwork for a free
addition to their solar product
I have reviewed the response from Titan
solar and the new panel should be
installed quickly we'll be watching to
make sure the daconas get what they've
been promised